[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la crise énergétique nous
amène à revoir nos organisations
domestiques comme professionnels afin
d'adapter nos consommations aux
ressources disponibles
vous nous annoncez cependant depuis
quelques jours des phases de délestage
de réseau ces couples locales limités
dans le temps impacteront l'ensemble des
usagers ménages entreprises services
publics les réseaux de communication
électroniques qui ont pourtant prouvé
leur caractère indispensable durant les
phases de confinement seront également
touchés
je souhaite donc attirer l'attention du
Gouvernement sur le cas spécifique des
réseaux de téléphonie mobile qui a
chemine notamment les appels d'urgence
en effet en cas de coupure même
momentané les numéros d'urgence y
compris le 112 ne seront pas accessibles
sur des pas entiers de nos territoires
je pense notamment au secteur moins
dense qui se sont desservis que par un
seul pilote tout défaut d'alimentation
électrique entraînent alors une
impossibilité d'accéder au Service les
antennes n'étant pas considérées comme
des équipements prioritaires de surcroît
les éléments les plus structurants du
réseau pourraient être aussi concernés
la coupure de certaines antennes aura
des répercussions sur le réseau national
les opérateurs pourraient être par
exemple dans l'incapacité d'assurer des
missions de sécurité intérieure
c'est pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est double quelle garantie
pouvez-vous nous donner sur la
cheminement des numéros d'urgence vers
les centres de régulation en tout temps
et en tout point du territoire
envisagez-vous de donner un statut de
réseau essentiel au réseau de
communication je vous remercie